[Music]
and gassy guard news Oh Oh my walk is
extra Oh at Chipola yeah only Tripoli
not true many kind of places you see
have the avocado salsa this free Oh have
you had the real [ __ ] when they come up
to you with the stone as grinder thing
and then they get the avocado and they
open that [ __ ] up scoop it and then they
in front of you I've had that out of
fake place a security guard was fired
after his his at work fart videos went
viral
oh you should never be fuzzy do it
farting at the diamond then [ __ ] have
you security guard look here is a what
was he guarding security guard actually
[ __ ] guards anything really like my
friend's dad is a security guard and
he's even laziest [ __ ] I have
ever known in my life he's not stopping
anybody well this one's not like the
Federal Reserve I know it's supposed to
be guarded like all of our nation's -
but at that point I hope they have cops
point I think it's like highly-trained
human beings good call yeah so this dude
he this takes place in Florida he was
guarding a hospital Gatorland
yeah Gatorland and so his name is Doug
but he I'll get high or do something him
Doug you can't have anybody named Doug
yeah what do you got against thugs Doug
sound lazy they're unprofessional do you
know what productive Doug I don't I
don't know any Doug's other than the one
on the Nickelodeon not a lawyer
Doug's sound pretty [ __ ] lazy and
incompetent way up damn just defend all
the dogs [ __ ] duggle this is
different Doug Alyssa's like Douglas
between Douglas
like my siblings is like I'm on time I
do my work on you know it's no fun here
yeah rich white family yes
that's really great is really was duck
but he started this Instagram account
after he sent this for his friends a
group chat of him farting at work it was
so funny his friends were like oh my god
you had to start in history ground like
the world needs to see this and so they
come up with they came up with the name
Paul farts so you guys know Paul now I'm
gonna show you guys a video paul blart
mall good phases
[Music]
[Applause]
it's more of him being on his phone
right it's less about like that's the
reason that they cited yeah it's an
embarrassment but I can't even see who
he's guarding or like the company yeah
you don't know the security companies
like for the security company or the
hospital like no one knows which
hospital you worked out or which
security company you worked for but they
still fired do you think people were
coming into the hospital like oh oh [ __ ]
you're the part guy man yeah and then
they were like dude we're having enough
of this I didn't want a [ __ ] pictures
with you like you got it we had a little
girl sir who's just getting too famous
for the hospital he needs to go to a
doctor in the hospital
cuz that [ __ ] sounded like there was
debris it sounded very satisfying though
like it is disgusting he didn't look
like he was in pain
like you was relieved of course every
time a little bit that was shrapnel in
that [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna see the chair
like afterwards like crater Wildman
those are all brooch coach parts you
don't know what I got a hospital and
from lunch you go to the [ __ ] Roach
coach in you buy a burrito those are
those farts I forgot about Roach coaches
now cuz it's so popular oh yeah yeah
that's what they're called these picaros
roasts I would get at chorizo buddy oh
yeah they still have those out in front
of like a Home Depot yeah yeah yeah
or they would call them taco trucks taco
trucks what the [ __ ] me this article
advice Mike is running out of material
now you have know exactly the kind of
content advice advice was just about
under covering like some kind of like
diabolical no have you actually read I
used like the actual website there's so
much just like that's where I learned
about communities that love donkey
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] how many followers
is this guy's IG have so as of right now
he has 80 to keep farting bro a lot of
people like this who would sponsor gas-x
oh yeah that prevent his farts because
that's his moneymaker there I could see
this being as a form of what is it ASMR
I mean like people that are constipated
they feel like the bloating in their
stomach look and then they come across
this guy and they're like oh what if it
helps them fart and [ __ ] maybe so I'm
just listening to the [ __ ] fart noise
oh my god dude my mom has a funniest way
to [ __ ] alright so like she gets
constipated right so then like one time
when I was a kid I keep hear or sneezing
[ __ ] that's like what are you doing mom
and then she showed me that like she
would roll up the toilet paper into a
little little [ __ ] needle right and
then she would tickle her [ __ ] nose
so she could sneeze and the sneezing
would help rachets her yeah like every
time I hear going and I'm like yeah
she's shitty have you guys ever sneeze
shat before no cuz mine like it [ __ ]
hurts I always keep it separate I try to
keep that [ __ ] as separate as possible
if you have allergies have you ever
sneeze parted I have that [ __ ] hurts
don't you have it without [ __ ] these
days Burke that's just confusing cuz
it's stuck good I've sneezed hiccups
before that hurts like a [ __ ]
damn that's crazy my family would say um
they say it's a Mexican thing but I I
highly thought it is but they'd say like
if you're on the toilet and your concert
video are supposed to hit your knees
what he's like that like a funny ball
yeah what is this like your what is this
thing that the real looks like when the
doctor checks isn't your like yeah that
like on top here and you're right they
like kicks out be fool are you here
elbow welcome it's not a Chinese really
does that help you [ __ ] though [ __ ]
clapping from the toilet they just like
got him no no say hit it oh no okay just
a bit sure it's funny how like people
think I'm not gonna
an ambassador by the way it couldn't be
but you lived in Mexico yeah you
actually lived in you are the mess
within about fairness yeah yeah I
believe what you say I think Jill is the
East LA ambassador type of Mexican Frank
sure there's a there's like this kid at
church he got mad at me because he was a
younger kid cuz his mom told him that if
do you have the hiccups you're supposed
to spit in the air and have it land on
your face and I was telling him it
wasn't true because clearly it was a
prank right but his mom was pranking him
yeah he got mad at me because I told him
he was it chuckles my mom's got a liar
like you are so stupid kid you been
spitting on your face for the past hour
wow you're so dumb dude did you like
talk to the mom later and be like well
she told me she was telling him that it
was like a Korean thing and he'd be like
it's true I was like bro you've been
spitting on yourself for the past hour
dude you should've added to him should I
help you right now he's like mad at me
because he thinks I'm calling his mom a
liar all right little kid spit away you
[ __ ] dumbass it you got to spit
higher that's why it's not working no
you're supposed to hold your breath in
all three times that's what I do I do
that no one actually worked at all
nothing works for me when I was little
my mom would tell me to get like a cup
of water and then bend over and then
drink it upside down that would help
sink water upside down see uh you need a
strong no like well show us what you do
with this right sucking your own like
you're sucking it makes it go away
it helped me oh [ __ ]
you still do it to this type of Adele
but if ever seats have been over like in
the office she drives her here that [ __ ]
okay fine but you got to show you guys
roll it up a taco shell this [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]